قالت زوجته النائبه في البرلمان التونسيه
المنحل والقياده في حركه النهضه الصحبه
عتيق ان الحاله الصحيه لزوجها المضرب عن
الطعام في تدهور مستمر واضافت زينب
المرايحي في منشور على فيسبوك ان زوجها
المعتقل منذ 15 يوما لم يتم استدعائه
للتحقيق حتى الان واكلت المرايحي ان الهدف
الوحيد لتوقيف زوجها هو ايداعه السجن
محمله قاضيه تحقيق المسؤوليه عن حياته
وبعد من تونس زينب المريحي زوجه القاضي
بحركه النهضه الصحبه عتيق
زينب اهلا وسهلا بك
ما التدهور الذي حدث في حالته
الحقيقه زوجي تعرض او انه عن تمر بظروف
صعبه خاصه على مستوى داخل السجن نتيجه
معناتها قضيه كيديه تلفيقيه تزويريه اقل
ما يقال عنها
رغم بحث كل التهم
بالبراهين والادله في ذلك يتعرض الى ظلم
مزدوج الان هو الان في السجن مع تشويه
خارج السجن لهو لعائلته نتيجه معناتها ظلم
كما قلت قضيه كيديه ليس هناك معناتها ولو
اثبات واحد على ذلك ولا يمت ولا تمت له
بصله ذوي الجراف هذا الظلم ليست له وسيله
سواء الاضراب على الجوع لان نرفض كل
الوسائل الاخرى زوجي صحته متدهوره معناتها
وصعبه زرته اخر مره
معناتها هو معنتها يقوم باضراب الجوع برفع
المظلمه
سلطت عليه
كل كما قلت كل مؤيدات تقول ذلك
الملف فارغ وبالتالي يمكن القول ان هذه
القضيه هي قضيه معنتها ترتقي الى مستوى
الفضيحه الدوله فنحن نعرف ان
المجتمعته
هل زوجك يعاني من اي امراض مثلا
سابقه على الاعتقال ام ان التدهور حدث
بسبب اضرابه عن الطعام
المعذره السؤال مره اخرى بالنسبه للحاله
الصحيه بالنسبه للحاله الصحيه للسيد
الصحفي هل هل هو لديه يعني يعاني من اي
امراض ام ان التدهور حدث بسبب اضرابه عن
الطعام
في
مساله اخرى
مساله
اخرى فاني احمل المسؤوليه المحمل
المسؤوليه كامله الى قاضي التحقيق الذي
اصدر بطاقه ايداع بالسجن في حق زوجي خاصه
ان الملف فارغ ليس له ما يدين زوجي فالملف
في القضيه تعود الى 2016 المتهم موجود
المتضرر موجود المحجوز موجود
وانت صاحب المال يقول ليست ليست ولكن
يسرون على معناتها اتهام زوجي بهذه
المساله والحاقه كيدا خاصه اذا علمنا ان
المتهم له السبب العدليه ومحجوز الان
معناتها الان في قضيه مخدرات له شهر من
ايقاقي هنا علامه استفهام ولكن
وتماشي انا مع المسار الذي تعيش وتونس
فانا معناتها اقول انها قضيه سياسيه
بامتياز الهدف منه هو ايجابي معناتها وضع
زوجي في السجن ثم نبحث له عن تهمه فيما
ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك يا سيده زينب البرايحي
زوجه القيادي بحركه النهضه المعتقل الصحبي
عتيق